[Captions by Y Translator]
In previous videos,
you guys have seen
Nate make dry ice bubbles
that you can actually bounce
and play with.
Now, Nate has a tendency
to try and eat pretty
much anything he can.
So, today we're actually
going to put a twist
on those dry ice bubbles.
We're going to make
them edible,
so you can use them
for fun Halloween toppings
in your drinks.
[Music]
>> Guys, Cali's back
here in the studio
and she's going to be showing us
how to adapt a project
we've done previously,
and make it a little bit
more food grade.
>> Because you eat everything.
>> That's sometimes true.
In the past, we've made
some bubbles that we fill
with dry ice vapor and looks
really cool because it's full
of just a white fog.
And, then they pop
and it releases the fog.
Cali has found a way
to make those bubbles edible.
So, we can fill them
with dry ice and put them
on the top of the drink.
So, you have a sort of spooky,
bubbly-filled,
ghost drink topper.
We captured some ghost souls
and we put them in bubbles,
and we're putting those
in our drinks.
>> That wasn't in the fine print.
>> That's what we're doing.
Some people call it dry ice,
but I call it ghost souls.
>> I have to go.
So, here's the basic idea.
We're going to be
taking some pretty
common kitchen ingredients.
We're going to be putting them
together, that will actually hold
in bubble shape,
fill them with dry ice and see
if we can put them on the top
of some drinks.
So, the ingredients that we
are using are pretty simple,
pretty easy to find.
Corn syrup and dish soap,
you're usually going to find
in your kitchen.
Glycerin can usually be found
in any baking section
or pharmacy section
of any department store.
>> We also have
a good variety of sodas,
which we primarily picked
because they were fun colors,
I'm pretty sure.
First, let's do a recap.
Let's make some of the regular
dry ice-filled bubbles,
the non-edible kind,
and then we can see what's
different between the two,
once we've got them all made.
>> I will be surprised
if you don't try
and eat one of those too.
>> Yeah.
>> So, for the non-edible bubbles,
we're actually going to take
some Dollar Store
bubble solution.
Going to use that for just
a little bit of the base,
but it's not really strong
enough to make these as large
as we want.
So we're going to add
a few other things too.
Just a little bit of this
and then if you can add,
probably I would say,
half a teaspoon of Glycerin.
There you go.
We're going to add
a little bit of water.
And then two full teaspoons
of Dawn dish soap.
I really made
this stuff powerful.
Oh, the power.
Okay, let's see if it works.
Hey, it works!
Don't eat these ones.
No...
Now let's add some dry ice.
And go.
Add more.
More.
Yeah, that should do it.
>> It's too much, it's actually
building up pressure.
>> No, no, that's actually
exactly what we want.
So take the lid off.
So the lid is how
we're going to control...
how fast we're building
these bubbles.
Build me a bubble.
>> Oh, just one at a time.
Look at that.
Honestly, you can test a lot
of different dish soaps, Dawn,
for some reason,
everybody agrees...
it works the best.
Look at this.
That's--
that's insane.
If you do this with bare hands
or rubber gloves
or anything like that,
the bubbles aren't really
going to stay.
They want this soft fabric,
and then you can pretty
much-- not drop them.
So if you want a lot
of dry ice vapor very quickly,
drop your dry ice
into hot water.
It's not going to last as long,
but you're going to get
this crazy opaque material here.
This is not recommended.
Nate's going to eat one
of the ones that
should not be eaten.
How'd that taste?
>> Like soap.
>> Do you want it to taste better?
>> Yes.
>> Let's fix that.
>> Okay.
Now we're going
to start making
our edible bubbles
and to do that,
we're going to start with soda.
Then we're going to take
a little bit of our soda
and we're going to throw it
in a pot on the stove.
And, the main reason for that,
is to just try and get all
of the carbonation out of it.
So for best results,
really just dump out some soda,
leave it on the counter
until there is,
no carbonation left.
This tends to be a slightly
faster way to do it,
but we do want to avoid it
boiling and we also
want to avoid it
hitting any sort
of caramelization stage.
>> We would also be able to just
put in a vacuum chamber
and suck all
of the carbonation out
like that.
>> Kind of like,
when you shake up a soda,
and then you pour it out
and you lose a lot
of that carbonation.
The idea is to just
really agitate the soda,
so we get rid
of that carbonation.
So you can see now
when I'm stirring it,
we're really not getting
any bubbles coming
to the surface.
It's basically just what
you would see on any liquid
on the stove.
That's what we're looking for.
No more carbonation,
so we're good to go.
So, we are going
to be adding one
similar ingredient that we added
to the regular bubble solution
and that is Dawn dish soap.
So while these bubbles
are edible,
you don't want to drink them.
They're wonderful
for the topping of a drink.
if you just want
to blow them and kind of
catch them in the air
with your tongue,
but maybe don't drink
the whole solution.
>> So let's talk, about how much
of this dish soap are we adding
into our mixture here?
>> Much less than we added here.
This was almost 3 tablespoons
by the time we were done.
This we're going to do
maybe half a tablespoon
and we're adding
other ingredients as well.
So that by the time you're done
it's less than a drop or so
of Dawn dish soap per drink.
>> Probably even less
than that even,
because once we've made
the bubbles, the actual
amount of liquid
used in bubbles,
it's going to end up only
being a few drops and each
of those few drops will only
contain about one
or two percent Dawn dish soap.
So... it's really
such a small amount
that it's really not a problem.
>> So here's what
we're going to do
to make it a little bit thicker.
We're going to be adding
some corn syrup,
which is just augmenting
the sugar that we have
in the soda already and then
glycerin which is going
to help the surface tension
of the bubbles.
Corn syrup about 2 tablespoons.
Glycerin, I'm going to say...
less than half a tablespoon or so.
>> Now, Glycerin like this soap,
is not something you want to eat
or drink a lot of but
in very small quantities such
as we're going to be having
in the bubbles on top
of our drinks,
it's not going
to cause any problems.
>> You get a bubble,
but it won't release.
Better than I thought.
Okay.
So you will see
that these bubbles
aren't forming nearly as large
as they are with a straight Dawn
dish soap-sort of solution.
So what we're going to do
instead is we're going to make
these bubbles even smaller
so that when you put them
on the top of the drink
filled with dried ice,
it's going to look really foamy,
really frothy,
and then when they pop,
you're going to get
that really cool smoke effect.
So the way we're
going to do that,
is just a small piece
of craft store mesh.
In case you're wondering
about the bubbly taste,
if you like,
stick your finger
in this and lick it,
yeah, you can taste bubbles,
but I did feed a drink to
my roommate without telling him
what was in it,
and he was fine.
Nate, which drink
are you choosing?
>> This is a strawberry pop,
is what it's called
and it's just got
a nice red color.
So we're going to try that.
All right.
Well, let's add some dry ice.
Same process.
So we're controlling the flow
of the dry ice fog with the lid.
So we're going to go
pretty slow here.
So, let me dip it first.
All right and go for it.
How about that?
Try and blow bubbles.
Now we're just making a mess.
>> It's what I'm good at--
>> But a cool mess.
>> That's one heck of a fancy,
bubbly drink.
>> So every single one of these
is actually an edible drink.
We just wanted to find
the weirdest sodas possible.
We've got blue-- Peach.
Pete--
Oh, that's Peach flavor.
This is--
That's a lemon lime.
This one is grape,
of all things.
This was strawberry and this
is a homemade butter beer.
This one is mine.
>> Let's add bubbles.
Yeah.
Keep going, keep going.
Next one!
Oh, too far!
Move it, move it, move it, move it--
They're going--
they're just-- at this point
it's just becoming--
>> It's bringing the cups closer.
>> I know, it's becoming one piece.
Now, let's refill the ones
that have gone out.
>> Go, go, go.
>> All right, so we
have made some food-safe,
carbon dioxide-filled bubbles,
and one more thing that
we want to try,
is this chocolate-covered,
maple-smoked,
bacon-flavored soda,
which sounds
like the worst thing ever,
but maybe that's just
because I'm not Canadian.
I don't know...
So I'm going to try this,
so is Cali.
I would say that taste
like Tootsie Rolls mixed
with burnt peanut butter.
Your turn.
>> What is in this?
Grant, you're Canadian,
maybe you'll like this stuff.
>> Chocolate-covered,
maple-smoked, bacon soda.
>> And, look at-- breakfast
in a bottle, it says.
>> Yeah.
>> No, it's a health food.
>> There's really nothing
more Canadian than that.
How do you describe what
that taste like, honestly?
I'm sticking with--
You know, it tastes
like chocolate-covered,
maple-smoked bacon.
>> I didn't actually get
any bacon flavor in there.
>> I wonder if anybody else
has ever tried this before
and can tell me what they taste.
Like, is there a better
description for this?
>> Guys, that's all for now,
but we've got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top
will take you directly
to our most recent video,
and you should go
check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next
and if you aren't subscribed
to our channel yet,
just hit this bomb
to get in the club
and that way you'll never
miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.